depuis des décennies la cité les bergée
des gens qui vivent avec la maladie
mentale mais cet automne la propriétaire
rosente Desjardins a décidé de vendre
son entreprise
[Musique]
oui madame les 8 résidences accompagnés
par le réseau de la santé doivent
déménager
la maison est vendue il faut déménager
non non
l'établissement de Rosanne Desjardins
étaient propres et bien tenues elle
aurait voulu continuer mais se dit
submergé par les exigences du réseau de
la santé
plus la Ville de Longueuil plusieurs
propriétaires de lieu d'hébergement en
santé mentale prennent la même décision
ce qui aggrave le manque de place au
Québec on compte maintenant en 1100
personnes en attente d'une place pour un
hébergement en santé mentale dont 630
uniquement sur l'île de Montréal on a de
plus en plus de cas complexes on a de
plus en plus une population
vieillissante en ce moment qui nécessite
des soins adaptés le réseau tente de
développer de nouvelles places plus
adaptées mais en attendant plus de
patience se retrouve attendre plus
longtemps dans les départements de
psychiatrie je vous dirai nous au niveau
de la santé mentale de façon générale je
veux parler de façon très générale on
tourne autour de
dose à 17% des gens qui sont en NSA dans
nos optomes en clair ça veut dire que 12
à 17% des lits de psychiatrie sont
occupés par des patients qui devraient
être sortis de l'hôpital il y a
peut-être 5 ou 6 ans quand on avait un
jeune par exemple qui avait besoin d'un
foyer de groupe on travaille avec la
traverse sociale est généralement à
l'intérieur de trois six semaines on
trouvait quelque chose maintenant on est
dans des délais de
4-5-6-7-8 mois ce qui transforme
certains patients en résidant à long
terme des départements de psychiatrie
200 jours 300 jours 400 jours des gens
qui sont bien des gens qui ont des
longues sorties des gens qui habitent à
l'hôpital qui mange à l'hôpital qui
habite à l'hôpital et parce que c'est
lié de psychiatries sont occupés trop
longtemps plus de patients aux prises
avec des problèmes de santé mentale
doivent prendre leur mal en patience sur
des civières à l'urgence un autre
problème qui contribue à l'engorgement
record de cet automne au Québec ici
David gentil Radio-Canada Montréal